so yesterday we learned that one of
Donald Trump's closest advisors his own
son-in-law Jared Kushner has been using
private email since December for white
house related work and we previously had
learned that vice president Mike Pence
was using private email I believe an
actual AOL account congressman jason
Chaffetz did the same thing Kris Kobach
used one while he was on Donald Trump's
voter suppression Commission and a bunch
of other senior Trump officials and
staffers Kellyanne Conway Sean Spicer
Steve Bannon they all had private email
servers and they were using them during
and related to their work with Donald
Trump in the administration we can now
add another name to that list because
Trump's own daughter Ivanka Trump also
one of these high-powered advisers has
been using a personal email account for
government work how do we know we have
documents that the nonprofit American
oversight obtained through a FOIA
request a Freedom of Information Act
request and shared the results of that
request with Newsweek but it's all about
Hillary's emails the real scandal here
is actually not the emails the emails
are relevant because of the hypocrisy
and the double standard the real scandal
is what qualifies Ivanka Trump to be
doing any White House or government work
what qualifies her dad is also a fair
question I guess it's kind of the same
question because this was never really
about Hillary Clinton's private email :
Powell said numerous times he had a very
similar system in place to the one that
that Hillary Clinton had endless Trump
staffers have used private email it was
never actually about Hillary's email it
was about a coordinated attack campaign
trying to find something that would
stick period Benghazi worked for a
little while and then it wasn't really
experiencing the cachet that Republicans
would have wanted and the Hillary email
stuff had had a bunch of more successful
impact from the point of view of
Republicans and it's not just the Trump
administration that's in a glass house
and throwing stones on emails remember
it's been widely reported I mean this is
it's years in the past and there's no
question about it
the George W Bush administration lost 20
two million emails between 2003 and 2009
and those emails were stored on a
private email server owned by the
Republican National Committee there is a
requirement under the presidential
Records Act that correspondences be kept
by people within the president's
immediate staff and advisers federal
employees are also required to maintain
records under the federal Records Act
didn't happen under george w bush oh
well things happen right things happen
and most of these attacks that were
hearing from the right are throwing
stones from glass houses 88 members of
the bush administration used private
email servers there were thirteen
Benghazi's attacks on american embassies
and consulates resulting in sixty deaths
during the George W Bush administration
only Benghazi with Hillary as Secretary
of State
seems to matter to the Republicans
Ronald Reagan gave undocumented
immigrants amnesty but it's bad when
Obama proposes a path to citizenship
Ronald Reagan came out in favor of
banning assault weapons but it's only
bad when it's Obama that does it Obama
cares individual mandate was the idea of
the right-wing Heritage Foundation
think-tank but it was okay then it's bad
when it's part of Obama care we could do
an hour Pat of these because it's never
really about the merits of the attack
it's about who can we smear using this
talking point and it's not just
hypocrisy too because Ivanka Trump and
Jared Kushner used private email after
the Hillary Clinton debacle took place
so they weren't even cognizant of the
fact that this could backfire that they
were doing the exact same thing that
Trump criticized Hillary for yeah if we
found out well years ago they did this
okay well that's one thing they created
some of these email accounts after the
entire campaign against Hillary Clinton
was in great part based on but her
emails and you know as far as Ivanka
suffering consequences goes there is not
going to be any consequences for Ivanka
Trump Ivanka Trump should not even be
involved with this administration but
she is and with Ivanka I don't know if
anyone else has noticed when it's
convenient Ivanka Trump is she's a good
kid
she's daddy's girl and then when it's
convenient she's a competent
representative of the United States like
when she sat in for Trump at that g20
meeting despite having no formal
position in the White House and actually
being barred from having one by
anti-nepotism laws so this is really
about understanding not only the
hypocrisy the hypocrisy is always there
but it's about understanding that a lot
of the attacks we hear are not really
attacks on the merits their attempts to
get the optics to stick and with
Hillary's emails it really worked very
very well supporting the program today
is the new war EP from independent
artist types from Grand Rapids Michigan
it is a multi genre progressive humanist
album that's a direct response to the
ongoing culture war in America here is a
clip from the song schouten
[Music]
you can hear this song and many others
in their entirety at types
VanCamp calm that is types with four T's
TT TT y PE s VanCamp calm you can also
find exclusive demos and live recordings
on the types patreon and the types
YouTube page all of which are spelled
with four T's